Hello world. It's the Raj,
welcome to this live stream. Uh,
if for those of you who are in my
previous life stream and doing one again,
because why not? Uh, thank
you guys for coming today.
What we're going to do is we're going
to find the relationship between student
test scores and the amount
of hours studied. Now to us,
clearly there must be some kind of
relationship, right? The more you study,
the better your test score will be.
But let's prove that mathematically
by using a strategy called linear
regression. So linear regression is a
very simple machine learning technique.
And the way we're going to optimize it
is by using probably not probably the
most popular optimization method
there is gradient descent.
So in this live stream you're going to
learn about gradient descent and linear
regression. So this is going to
be awesome. So get ready for this.
I'm glad to see that there are some
cool people in the room right now.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to
first talk about conceptually how we're
going to do this and then we're going
to implement it mathematically and
programmatically.
It's really the same thing in the yet.
So let's pull up what we need to pull up.
A great guy, good number of people in
here. So let's go ahead and do this.
So the first thing we want to do, so
what I have up here is uh, is a, uh,
visualization. It's an animation
of what this looks like. Okay.
And uh, it's going to start
off as a horizontal line.
We want to find the line of best fit,
we want to find the line of best fit so
that using this line we can then predict
what a student's test score will be
given the amount of our studied or vice
versa.
But how do we get that line of best fit?
We'll we're going to use
gradient descent to do that.
And so this is just a visualization of
what the gradient descent process will
look like to get there.
Okay.
And gradient descent is used everywhere
in machine learning and deep learning.
Okay. We think about everything in terms
of optimization where we have some loss
function that we want
to minimize overtime.
And gradient descent is the
technique we use to do that. Okay.
And so we're going to talk about that.
So let me start off by answering, uh, um,
I'll do a two minutes worth of Q and a
for questions and then we'll get right
into the code. So, hey, how's it going?
Okay, we've got some, any questions?
Questions about deep learning, AI,
machine learning,
uh,
waiting for the wrap we'll see was well,
yes. Questions. Questions really are the,
the great thing to have in the beginning.
Do Ama with other people.
Okay.
So I'll give it,
I'll give it 10 more seconds.
Ten nine, eight, seven.
We're about to get into this.
We are about to get into it.
Once I started there was no stopping.
I'm like an Oreo that really has no
relationship to what I just said.
Can we do Q and a after the
end of the session? Yes we can.
So we're going to do Q
and a every 15 minutes.
So right now there are no
questions because no one
knows what the hell is going
on. Is there any other method to
get leased? Square error? Yes.
The method we're using here
is the sum of squared error.
There are plenty of methods to do it,
but this is the most used one.
And one more question is,
is linear regression like this ml or DL?
Now that is a great question.
Linear regression is just ml.
It's machine learning.
There is no neural network,
but the reason I'm doing this
is to demonstrate gradient
descent because you're
going to use this in almost
every neural net that you built.
You're going to use this
all over the place. Okay, so
that's it for the questions.
Save your questions every 15 minutes
I'm going to be answering questions and
this livestream will be an hour long,
more or less.
So let's get started with the code,
shall we?
And thanks to you Udacity for
hosting this. By the way, here we go.
So
yeah,
to do this, let's look at our data first.
What is the data that we have? How do we,
this is the Dataset
that we have by the way.
So the data set is a collection of
test scores and amount of our study.
So the x values are on the left hand
side and those are the amount of hours
studying. So right here, 53 a 61.
These are the amount of our study
and the y values are the test scores.
Let's prove this relationship. That's
our dataset. It's in a data dot CSV file.
You can find it on my get hub.
It is at the very top.
It is the most recently
updated code repository.
It might be the description as
well. Uh, I'm not sure if it's not.
I would appreciate it if it is.
So let's get it.
Go ahead and get started with the code.
So the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to define the, let's see,
the main function. I hope the code
is, uh, it is visible for you guys.
You guys are going to code.
Yes.
But what I want you to do is I want you
to pull up an editor, a text editor,
and I want you to code with me.
So pull up sublime text,
pull up Adam and start
coding with me. Okay. So
let me get everything all
set up here are great.
So the first thing we're gonna do is
we're going to say we're going to find our
main function.
And
okay,
it's just a standard thing.
We always do this, don't we?
Sometimes you just have
to do things that you,
it's not really necessary,
but we'll go ahead and write that out.
So that's it for our main function.
And now we're going to define
the real main function,
which is it our run function.
This is the highest level.
So let's define our steps here.
The first thing we want to do,
and this is what we do in machine
learning, is we pull our Dataset,
we parse our dataset into memory so that
we can then run our algorithms on it.
So the data set is going to be a
collection of points on an x, y plane.
So we're going to say Jen from text.
And the way we even have
this method available,
Jen from taxed is by pulling from num Pi,
which is,
are very, are very much used
machine learning library.
Almost almost every,
uh,
machine learning repository is
going to import num py in some way.
And if it doesn't directly,
it's going to happen under the hood.
Num Pi is the matrix multiplication
library for machine learning.
Okay.
Uh,
I have paid version of sublime. I'm
working on a different laptop than mine.
We had some issues, so, uh, I just,
I just downloaded this version was
flying it and don't worry about it.
So what we're gonna do is we're
going to say Jen from tax,
I'm gonna make this a little smaller
because this line is going to be kind of
big. We're going to say data dot CSV. So
that is our CSE file that we just, uh,
used.
And now I'm going to say delimiter.
So this is just basic data parsing and
this method is from num py by the way.
And that star little symbol,
it's a cow.
Let's US pull it without having
to say NP or num py every time.
So let's get our delimiter value
and that's going to be a comma.
So the comma just means let's split it
by the comma and the comma is what's in
between these values. If we were to
look at it in terms of a raw txt file,
there'll be a common with common between
the hour study and the test scores.
So it splits them both into, uh, uh,
a set of points, x, y value pairs.
So that's our, those are our points. Okay.
And so the next part is the learning rate.
The learning rates is going to be 0.01.
What the hell is this?
So learning rate is a hyper parameter.
This is a hyper parameter.
And hyper parameters in machine
learning are what we use
as tuning knobs for our model.
So we have a bunch of these,
and right now this is
the only one we have.
The learning rate defines how fast our
model Lawrence. So you might be thinking,
well, why don't we just set the
learning rate to a million? Well,
the reason is like all things in
machine learning, it's a balance.
It's kind of like a bell curve. So, uh,
if the learning rate is too low,
our model will never converge.
And if it's too high, then the
model will, uh, take, sorry.
If the learning rate is too low, our
motto will be, uh, too slow to converge.
Whereas if it's too high, our model will
never converge. So we want that balance,
that optimal learning rate.
And in this case it's going to be
0.01 in general in machine learning,
we don't always know off the top of our
head what the best hyper parameters are
going to be.
So we have to guess and check now in the
bleeding edge of machine learning and
deep learning right now is to learn
what those hyper parameters, uh,
we'll be okay.
So
that's it for that part.
And let's just keep going here because
we were on a roll. So that's our, our,
that's it for our learning, right?
And then we have our initial B value,
which is going to be zero.
And then we have our initial m value,
which is going to be
zero. What is this? Well,
this is our y equals mx
plus B function from,
from Algebra. We have the
slope formula, so that,
so the B is our y intercept and
the m is our slope. It is the,
the ideal slope that we want.
So we're going to start off with zero
because we're going to learn these values
over time.
Right now it's just be an m there's zero,
but we're going to learn them over time.
So that's,
that's our initial values for art.
So this is the slope formula.
That's it to start off with.
And now we have our number of iterations.
So how many, how many iterations
do we want to run our, uh,
our training? Step Four. So we're going
to say a thousand. Why a thousand? Well,
because we have such a small data set.
If the data set was bigger,
then we would have to do 10,000 or
100,000 start incorporating gps and stuff
like that. But we'll start off
with just a thousand. Okay. So
there is that.
And now I want to print
out the starting grow.
Well, we'll forget the prince
step. We don't really need
that right now. Okay. So,
so now we're going to say,
uh,
let's get those ideal bnm values.
Let's get the ideal bnm values by
using the gradient descent runner step.
Now this is where the logic is going to
happen, which we're going to define now,
right? So this is the highest value.
And then we're going to print out what,
what be Nmr. So print, uh, print B,
and then print him depending on what the,
the,
those are going to be the optimal value.
So this step is going to output the
optimal values for each of them.
So what we're going to feed it is we're
going to feed everything we've just
defined. We defined our points,
we define that initial p value.
We defined the initial m value,
we defined the learning rate,
we defined a number of iterations,
we defined a couple of things.
And so we're going to speed
this all into the model. Okay?
So that's it for the highest level.
And okay,
so now what we're gonna do
is we're going to get into
the gradient
descent runner step.
So the gradient descent runner step
is going to be defined now. Okay,
so let's look at what this looks like.
Given our values that we defined,
which were the points and the starting
be value and the starting value and the
learning rate and the
number of iterations. Okay,
so let's do this. Okay, who's with me?
We've got the B values.
The B value to start off with
is going to be what we gave it,
which is zero and the m value as you
can guess is also going to start off as
zero. They'll both start off at zero.
We've got to learn these things.
This is machine learning.
It's not machine define it statically,
so for I in range number of iterations,
which is which are a thousand
we're going to say, well,
let's get those values.
Okay?
Using something called the step gradient.
Now that is where the real good stuff
happens. That's where it's at. Okay?
We're going to define that,
but given what we start off with that B,
which is zero in the m
and the array of points,
so we're going to take those points.
The x y value pairs and
feed it in as an array,
we can convert that to an array
by using this function array.
And then the learning rates, which is
a static value. It's a constant value.
Okay?
All right. And I will answer
questions in three minutes.
So we have that for our learning rate
and then we're once we're done with that.
So for all of those iterations, once we
have that, those optimal values for Bnm,
we'll return them and then
we can print them in that,
that highest level function.
Okay? So that's for bnm.
That's our grading, the
samp runner step. Now,
now it's time to define this
a
step. Great in function. So now we're
going to define the step radiant function.
Step gradient is going to be we given
the current B and given the current ham,
yeah.
Uh, we're going to give it the
points and then the learning rates.
Okay,
so now we're going to define
how gradient descent works.
All of it is going to happen in this step,
but before we do that,
before we do that,
let's write another function.
So let's put this on hold for a second.
We're going to get to this,
but let's write another
very important function.
So we have two functions left in
this code really, but it's the,
the real meat of it is going
to be explaining what they are.
It's the step radiant and
we have one more function,
which is the compute error for given
points function given B m and the points.
So this, we're going to write
this one first. Let's talk
about what this is. Okay,
so I have great visualization
here and we're going to
talk about what this is.
So
when we start off with this slope,
it's going to be zero, right?
It's just a horizontal line.
And then you see this is
what's happening in the code.
You see that it's going up like that.
I love how the code is behind me.
I can just do this. You see it going
up. So how does it get up? Well, for us,
what we want to do is we want
to compute an error value.
And what does that error value?
How do we,
it's a way of for us to estimate how bad
our line is so we can update it every
time, every step, every in machine
learning, we call it time step,
every time step. We want you to
improve our model's prediction.
And to do that we need an error die you
in this. Sometimes they call it error.
Sometimes they call it loss error loss.
It means the same thing we went to
minimize error. We want to minimize loss.
And the way to do that is to
compute what that error is.
And depending on the use case, it could
be different things. In this case,
simple linear regression.
We have a set of points we want to,
we want to uh,
define what that error is.
So here's what it is we have,
we start off with the line
and we have a set of points.
And what we want to do is we want to
measure the distance between each of those
points at a certain time step.
So just imagine the line is static.
So for each time step, the line
is static. It doesn't move.
We want to measure the distance
from each point to the, um,
to the line. So we want, it's called
the sum of squared errors. Okay?
So a sum of squared errors
is the name of this.
And so what this looks like is
if we were to look at an image,
it looks like this,
given some points,
let's measure the distance from each of
those points to the line that we have
drawn and then square them and then sum
them all together and then divide by the
number. So it's divide by
the total number of points.
And that is our error value.
And you can,
and we want to minimize that error value.
So just think about minimizing this error.
How are we going to minimize it?
That's the next step, gradient
descent. But right now,
this is how we calculate our error.
This is how we calculate our air.
And,
uh,
okay,
so now let's,
uh,
take some questions for five minutes and
then we're going to get back into the
error value.
Why am I so stupid? So let's
stop this self deprecation. Okay.
No one is stupid. It's just
about who knows? These facts.
These are static facts.
Who has spent the time and
energy to study this stuff. Okay.
No self deprecation.
You guys are awesome for even being here.
This stuff is the most important
stuff in the world. Okay.
Can we use machine to not
for nonlinear equations? Yes.
This is a linear equation but yes we
can use it for non linear equations
for very, very high dimensional data. Yes.
400 dimensional data but we will
get there when we get there.
Could you make the font smaller?
Yes, I can do that. Okay.
Two more questions and then we're going
to get right back into computing this
error value programmatically
and mathematically could.
Why is python better except for
the object oriented programming?
Python is as my friend who works on
the tensorflow team at Google says the
Lingua Franca of machine learning. It
is the language and why is it? Well,
there's a couple of reasons.
One,
it just had that headstart that people
who were the first to to to do machine
learning algorithms decided that they
wanted to use python and we just kind of
build from there.
That's one.
Two is the amount of libraries that we
now have four and three is because it's
just a dope language. Python is awesome
if you've coated in it for a while,
you realize, wow, this,
this does a lot of things that other
languages should do in a lot less code.
It's more efficient. And
if you've come from a, uh,
an ios background with objective C,
if you've come from a c black background,
a c plus plus background,
we don't have to deal with deadlocks.
We don't have to deal with memory leaks.
All of this is done by our interpreter.
And we can just focus on what matters,
which is the algorithms.
And so that's why python is used
because we can focus on the algorithms.
One more question.
Can you make a video about different
layers in a neural network? Uh,
we'll see. We'll see. I don't know
exactly what you mean by that.
That's why I said that. So, okay. So now
let's get back to computing this error.
So how do we compute this?
So get ready for some math and I'm
gonna explain what's happening here.
So this is the error equation.
Okay.
So this is how we compute
that sum of squared errors.
So get ready for this. Okay, a
little refresher on on this. This is,
this is Algebra, okay? We
have our y value, which is uh,
the y value for a point, okay? And
then we have minus mx plus B. Well,
what is mx plus B? Will it just
turns out that y equals mx plus B,
right? So y equals mx plus B is the
same. Mx Plus B is the same thing as y.
So we have two points. We
have the y point from our, uh,
from the Dataset and then we have the
wide point on our line and we want to
minimize the distance
between both of those points.
And so that's why we are subtracting them.
So we subtract the point from our data
set from the point on our line and then
we square it. Well, why do we
square it? Well, for two reasons.
One is because, uh, we want
the value to be positive.
We don't want to have to deal
with negative values. Why?
Because we are going to summit in a second
and two is because we don't actually
care about the, the value itself, we
just care about the magnitude from.
So we're looking at it from
a more abstract perspective.
We just care about the magnitude of these
values. We went to minimize magnitude.
So that's going to give us odd that the,
the difference between r a y intercepts
and then little refresher on this e that
means sigma, that's a, that's a notation
for that is called sigma notation.
And what it does is it defines a set
of values that we want to iterate over.
So what we're saying here is for when I
equals one up to n where n is the number
of points.
So for all of those points we went to uh,
measure the squared error values for
all of the points against our line.
And then one over n means we want,
you find the average of those and
that's going to give us one value.
And that one value is the error value.
This,
some of this squared errors.
And every time step we want to minimize
its value using gradient descent.
Okay?
Okay.
So let's define this programmatically,
the sum of the squared errors.
So we'll start off with error being zero.
It's just there is no area
we have to calculate it.
So what we're gonna do is we're going
to iteratively a compute this for every
point that we have. Okay?
So we're going to say four.
I in range zero.
So we start off with zero until bill.
The,
the ending point is the
number of points we have.
So that's the length of the
points given those points. Okay?
So for all the points, we're going to
do this, we're going to compute the air.
So get ready for this.
We're going to programmatically in code
or we're going to programmatically, uh,
complete that math, that equation that we
just saw. So we'll start off by saying,
well, what are the x values? And
we can find those x values by
saying I where I is zero.
So for the first column and in
the, in our Dataset, and then, oh,
sorry, in our array, right? Cause they're
their points. And then we're going to say,
well, what are our y
values? Okay, for one, so x,
y value. So right now we have
one x value and one y value.
And the four loop is because we're going
to continuously do this every time.
So let's compute that total error.
And so this line is going to represent
that equation that we just saw.
Okay? This is, this line will represent
that equation programmatically.
So we're going to say the total
air value is going to be a why.
Remember it's y minus.
We can literally just word
for or character by character.
Say what this is going to
look like m times x Plus B,
okay.
And then this means squared.
So we're going to square that and
then we're going to add it every time.
And so that's the sum
of the squared errors.
And uh oh well this part is just going
to give us the sum of the squared errors.
And then we have to,
we went to average it would that,
that one over n that we had here,
that's that next step.
So once we have all of these, we'll
divide it by the total number that we had.
Return.
Total error
value to the, Oh yes.
Thank you for saying that. I
did miss an eye. You got it.
Total error divided by float
over length times points.
Okay. It makes sense, doesn't it?
Anthony, I appreciate you being here.
Shout out to Anthony
Cooper. Uh, okay. So, um,
we've got total error divided by float
length might have won. So that's it.
That's what we had. That's our computing
error for our given points. Okay.
Even God's make errors.
Everybody makes errors.
Oh,
let's see. Let's see, let's see. Okay,
so now, and I'll answer questions
in six minutes. So every 15 minutes.
So let's keep going here.
That's it for our compute hair function.
So where were we?
We were in that last function and the
most important function because it's
talking about grading dissent.
Listen Up,
because this is going to be used almost
every time when you're using deep neural
networks all the time. No, this like
the back of your hand grading dissent.
Let's go, let's go tales. I got some, see,
I got some of my homies in here
at. Cool, so let's go with this.
We've got gradient descent.
Let's do this. So for B, gradient
starts off at zero and a four m gradient.
It's also a source of a zero. All
right, before we even code this,
let's explain what this is doing,
what the word gradient means.
Let's look at this. Not
that. Let's look at this.
What is this? This is a very
colorful rainbow period.
Let's get back to this. No,
I'm just kidding.
What this is is it's a graph
that shows three dimensions.
The three dimensions are,
and it's the same graph.
It's just looking at these
two images are the same graph.
It's just looking at it
from a different angle.
So let's just focus on this
one to not make it confusing.
We're just looking at one graph right
here and it's going to make the whole
thing smaller because that's how
math works. We have our y intercept,
we have our slope, and we have our
error. Okay. So what this is, it's,
it's a graph of all the
possible wine or steps,
all the possible slopes and
all the possible error values.
So remember that era
value that we calculated.
And so if we were to map all of
those triplets so they could,
we can think of them as triplets of x
are of slope y intercept and error value
pairs,
it would make this graph.
What we want to do is we want to find
that point where the error is smallest.
We want to find the point
where the error is smallest.
And if we look at this graph,
we can see what that point is visually.
It's going to be at the
bottom of the curve.
Now we call this in machine learning,
the local minima.
Now the reason we say local
as opposed to nonlocal, uh,
is because we have a
very simple graph here.
So sometimes there are many minimum and
we want to find, um, which minimize.
So that's that second order optimization.
Right now we're focused on
first order optimization.
So let's find that smallest point because
that smallest point at the very bottom
of this graph is going to give us
the ideal y intercept and slope.
So if we find the minimum
error, the minimal error,
the smallest error possible,
we'll also get the ideal y
intercept and the ideal slope,
the ideal bnm.
And what do we do with those ideal bnm
values while we plugged them into our y
equals mx plus B equation.
And what happens when we plugged them
into our y equals mx plus B equation.
We get the line of best fit.
Now I want to say, by the way,
this is not the optimal way
of doing linear regression.
We could compute these bnm values.
Uh, you think simple Algebra, uh,
it doesn't really require us
to do creating the descent.
We're only doing this strategy because
it's a way to learn gradient descent.
There are easier ways to do this, but we
want to do this the dope way. Okay? So
that's what that is. And so we're going
to compute this using grading dissent.
Okay? So greatest sense. So that was
the first part of the explanation.
And so if the reason I show this graph
is because the way we get that smallest
point is by calculating
what's called the gradient.
The gradient is also considered the slope.
Okay? Not to be confused with the, uh,
with the m value,
we're talking about a slope in the
direction of getting us to that gradient
value.
So we have some why value,
we have some B value and we want
to iteratively every iteration.
We have a thousand iterations when it
iteratively move our point where we are in
space in this three dimensional space,
down to that smallest point.
And the way we do that is by
calculating the gradients.
And the gradient gives us a direction.
It means slope, it means direction.
And we need to talk about this for a
second. This is important. Listen Up.
So gray and values are used all
over the place and machine learning.
So I was talking to Ian Goodfellow,
right?
He's the guy who invented
generative adversarial networks.
And he was saying that some, some, uh,
problems we can't do,
we can't solve because we
don't have the gradient.
So clearly gradients are
used across machine learning.
Sometimes in machine learning we
call functions differentiable it,
that's another word for,
uh,
can we compute the gradient from it
using what's called a partial derivative.
So to compute this
gradient value a direction,
it's a tangent line.
Essentially a,
a gradient descent is
essentially a tangent line.
It's going to give us a
direction. Direction means
positive or negative. Do we,
do we move up, do we, do we move down?
And so it gives us that line that,
that direction that we want to move.
And this is another example of,
of grading dissent.
It's essentially a bowl like curve,
a bowl I curve.
And this is also
okay,
an example of
bad internet connection or bad a server.
So this would probably be
better. So, so yeah, it's a bowl.
It's a bowl. We could think of this
entire process as a bowl and the ball are,
our x are the points that we are,
that we have,
whether that be the slope
or the y intercept and an
even more complex problems.
The features and the numbers and the
words for natural language processing.
It's all abstracted to a bowl like
problem where we are trying to find the
optimal point for that bowl.
It's going to give us to optimal values
that we need to make our model amazing.
Okay, amazing. Slash. Optimal.
Should we go up? Should we go down?
That's what the gradient gives us.
And to calculate that gradient.
And let me say this,
let's last thing and then we're going
to get right into the code to calculate
that gradient.
We're going to compute what's called
the partial derivative in calculus with
respect to our values and
our values, our B, and m.
So this is the equation
for the partial derivative.
Okay? For that that we're going
to, we're going to take this,
these equations,
these two equations,
and we're going to programmatically
encode them. No, this is the last part,
but it's also the most important part
because that is gradient descent.
So we start off with why minus mx plus B,
which is why,
okay.
And we compute the partial derivative.
So what that means is we differentiate,
uh,
this is from calculus. So we take
the V, the value, whatever it is.
So little refresher. So if we have, um,
let me just write this out actually. So
if we had an equation that was x squared,
what is a derivative of this? We
take the exponent, this is a two,
and we move it to the, uh,
in front of the variable.
So it'd be two X. Okay.
So that's a driven it,
but we are calculating the partial
derivative with respect to B and m.
So what does that, what do you
mean by partial? By partial,
I mean we're only using,
uh, the values that we, uh,
we're calculating a
derivative using only B,
and then we're calculating a respective
or a different partial derivative using
just m. Okay. So let's,
so this little symbol over here,
this little squiggly just means partial
may play. Find the squiggly. Okay.
And then let me also answer some questions
cause I think it's time to answer
some question. This, this little
squiggly means partial derivative. Okay.
So it's going to make a
lot more sense when we, uh,
and code code this
programmatically. If, if,
if you aren't as familiar with
the math terms. So questions.
Okay.
Why are there two equations?
There are two equations because we are
Tau collating respected derivatives for
both B and.
M.
Those are the two values that we are
trying to find and we're going to look at
this programmatically.
So two more questions and then
we're going to code this last step.
Nice. So gray and sent helps
us to put rainbows at the,
okay. Hey that's not okay.
Exactly.
Best use of time and money.
Will there always be one low
point in the error function?
We can work to using gradient descent
when we have a linear function?
Yes, because it is our local
minima but sometimes we have very,
very complex data.
We have data that has hundreds of
features. We have data that is unlabeled.
We have data that uh,
we don't,
sometimes we run unsupervised
algorithms. That means, uh,
algorithms that the delay,
the data is not labeled and we
try to find something from it.
So sometimes it clusters in certain
points and we say, oh, this cluster there,
there must be some relationship here
in, in, in more complex cases. No.
In more complex cases.
There are, um, there are,
there could be low there, there
could be several local minima and uh,
we want to find the ideal one, but
we'll get to that. Right? It's,
it's just another set up.
We want to learn where to do
gradient descent and that's,
that's later steps. Um, one more question
to start off with ml and AI,
do you recommend starting with
the Mln d followed by note?
Are there
why the gradient gives the minimum that
that is a mathematical question? Yes.
So why does the gradient give the minimum?
Because
it doesn't give us the minimum
to start off with the gradient.
Just skip tells us how
to update our value.
Should we update them with a positive?
Should we update them with a negative?
Should we multiply them by,
you know,
how do we modify our values to make them
closer and closer to the optimal values
where the error is the smallest
and once we're finally there,
that is our minimum. Okay. It
doesn't directly give us a minimal,
all it does is it gives us a direction
to minimize our error or loss. Okay.
If we can compute a gradient.
So that mean if a function
is differentiable,
then we know that we can optimize it.
So let's write this out.
Let's write out this step
grading function. Okay? So
we are, so we, we, we call this
function in our grading dissent runner.
Recall that we were weak,
we called it right here,
given the B m points and learning rates.
So now we're going to ride this out.
You have are,
okay,
so let me make this a little smaller so
we can really see what's going on here.
And uh,
zero m equals m gradient equals
zero n equals float length points.
Okay?
These are our initial gradient values
for B for further be great and the embryo
and we're going to update them over
time and it's going to be the number of
points. Okay? That's just
the number of points.
And now we're going to calculate
the gradient steps. So,
uh, okay. So for each of the points,
we're getting great and values for each
of the points and we're going to put
them all together and it's
gonna give us one, uh, uh,
optimal bnm for each time step or a
more optimal bnm had each time separate
member. This alone isn't going to
do it. We have to iteratively do it.
And that's what we did beforehand.
Yes.
Oh, you're right. Yes you are right. Yes.
Oh guys, you, you got me. I already
defined it over here. That's what's up.
I did define it here. Yes. Great.
Where was I moved down there.
There we go. Okay, so a grain of sand
runner. And then we have the yes,
the plot points and the n
value is the number of points.
Okay. So now let's, uh,
we're going to iterate through all of
those points that we just defined, right?
The points, the length of
the points, and then, uh,
so for each of those
x and y. Dot. U Paris.
So for points where I is zero,
where y is
not where I is,
zero for each of those. X, Y, Paris,
hi one.
Let's calculate the gradient.
So how do we do that? Well,
let me look back at this equation
and see what that was is,
okay?
So what we're doing here to calculate
this gradient or this partial derivative,
okay?
A is what we are doing is we are going to
take y mx plus B and then
multiply it by the x value.
Okay?
Um,
and then at a negative sign and then do
that for every point and then multiply
it by two over the number of points.
Okay? We can do that. Let's do that.
Remember, these are
laws. They are constant.
The partial derivative is the same every
time. It is a law is a fundamental law.
It is a beautiful law
because it's always the same.
It is predictable and predictability is
great sometimes when you need it to be.
So let's calculate that value
native to end.
That's what we had
negative two over n times.
Why?
Remember,
we are just writing it out just
like we just saw it in the equation.
It's the same thing.
Am current times x
Plus B,
current y minus mx plus
B times two over the end.
Uh, negative. And then we're
continuously adding that. Right?
So that's it for our grading for B,
that's going to give us a direction,
aren't positive or negative
that we should update via. Okay.
And then we want to do
the same thing for em.
So in fact, I'll just paste
it because it's very similar,
but it's a little different and I'll,
I'll show why it makes you,
make sure you guys can see it all.
For our m gradient,
it's going to be negative two n times x
Times y minus m current times x Plus B
current. Yes. Okay. So
we're doing this for every
point and we're going to see,
we're going to concatenate all of those
values together using this plus equals
function to get that, uh, be
gradient in the m gradient. Okay.
And so once we have those values,
we're going to use them.
Now it's time to use those values.
Okay.
To use those values,
we're going to update the
real bnm values using them.
And how do we, how do we use them? All
we say for let's say for B for example,
we take what we have currently for B,
whatever it is at every step,
because we're running this every time,
step,
every of a thousand minus the
learning rate times the B gradient.
This is why we define our learning rates
because we multiply it by the gradient
and it's going to,
uh,
it's going to convert it into
a value that we can then, uh,
it can either make it convergence slower,
it could never converge,
but this learning rate is going to
give us, uh, a good a convergence,
uh, uh, rate of convergence is gonna
give us a good rate of convergence.
And then we have the new M,
which is going to be m current,
same deal, minus the learning rates. And
I'll answer questions in four minutes.
So keep them ready,
times the gradients
return,
and then we'll return them
just like that.
Okay.
So what did we just do here?
Let me answer some questions.
Oh, okay. I
it is the learning rate.
It is the same thing.
I just defined it differently
in the, uh, the step. Okay.
So, yeah, so that's
for our gradient. Okay.
Can you please explain again why
we are doing Newbie and knew him?
So we had an initial bnm right. Those
words zero value, they were to zero,
we had nothing. We want it to
update them using the gradient.
So the gradient will tell us
how should we update them.
Should it should be be zero,
should be one,
should it be negative
one should be be 0.5.
The gradient is a value that we uh,
use to update the BNN value,
the initial bnm value to get
the new bnm value. To do that,
we're going to calculate
the partial derivative with
respect to B and respect to
m,
which are these two respective lines
right here given all of our points.
Okay. Given all of these
points were calculating,
that will sum them all up and then we'll
multiply it by the learning rate and
subtract that from what we have currently.
And that's going to give
us our new bnm values.
Okay.
So can you explain why do you multiply
the learning rate times the gradient?
Again, what's that value? So,
okay, so the learning rate,
if we,
so in a Dataset this small with
only a thousand data points,
we don't really need a learning rate
more or less. I mean we don't really,
our model is going to converge.
This is just good practice to always
think about a learning rate because we use
learning rates in deep learning, right?
We use them in deep neural networks.
It's about a balance.
You'll find that all of this stuff is all
about a balance time versus computing.
If a power versus efficiency
versus amount of code,
it's always a balance I'll learning rate
does is we are predefining how fast we
want our model to train.
And if we do it too fast then we'll
never converge. That means we'll never,
going to convergence means
finding the optimal, uh,
values for our function. Whatever
it is. If we do it too slow,
then it will be too slow to converge.
So it's about time and balance.
We've set 0.0001 for our learning right
here, statically ourselves manually.
But you know,
ideally we can learn what that value is.
The part where we sum it all up.
This is the last question someone asks,
what is the part where we sum it all
up? Is it in the four loop? Uh, yes,
it is in the for loop. We are summing
it all up right here. Plus equals.
We're summing it all up. Okay, so,
so yeah. So yeah, let's run this
code. That's it for the code.
Actually let's run this thing.
We've got python hundred
percent is going to be an error.
Okay.
Of course.
If name
hold on.
Oh yes. Two equal signs because
that's how we roll in Python.
What are you talking about here?
Deep learning is a subset of
machine learning. You are correct.
It is a subset.
And what we have here
is a space that, there we go. Okay.
So let's get to questions.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Oh, you know what it is is
because does this computer,
so I'm using a new computer by the way,
so it might not num Pi might
not be installed. We can
install with pit. Oh my God.
Okay, so here's what it
is. Here's what it is. So
let me look back at this.
What does that,
so I actually don't have an empire and
so on this computer I'm using a different
computer. This was a last minute thing.
Don't worry about it. The code works.
I just come,
I had a compiled earlier.
Look at the values here.
Uh, we've got the ideal after a thousand
iterations, B m and D, error value.
This happens in milliseconds because we
have such a small data set. And also, um,
no, no, no. Actually I do have num py.
Nevermind. I, cause I just compiled it.
What am I thinking? Hold on. So
let's see what we've got here.
Okay.
I'm going to do some debugging because
we've got some time. So why not? Let's,
let's debug Jen from tax is not
defined because we've defined it.
Right.
Interesting.
Also, this is the, this is the code
that I'm, that I'm reading it from.
There it is. Okay. So there it
is. So I'm actually curious what,
what the error was or was it,
it was
Jen from text,
but it wasn't defined because,
because,
oh, I misspelled it. That's
why de, okay. Anyway,
it's because I misspelled it. Uh, but
yes, I misspelled the gen from text,
so I've heard a thousand iterations.
We get the ideal be we get the ideal
and values both of them and we can plug
them into our equation
and it's going to give us
the optimal line of
best fit for our values,
which we can then use to make a prediction
given a test score or given a right.
That's what's up.
Yes. That's what it was. Jen from
txt, not Jen from t e x. T. That's,
that's exactly what it
was. Thank you. Okay. Can't
confirmed Illuminati confirmed.
So questions, any questions guys? This
is going to give us the, this is that.
This is what this code is
going to do right here.
Exactly right. When, when
it's all about winning. Okay,
so we've got any questions?
How many people do we have in here?
We have a good number to 42
that's a good number. Okay.
Single closed set of double how to use
the momentum technique in order to find
not only the local minima
momentum is something that,
okay,
we don't really use in linear regression.
We use that for a nonlinear
models with high dimensional data.
We'll talk that later. Uh, can
we use a dynamic learning rate?
That's a great question. Yes. Actually.
Um, if the learning rate adapts,
ideally, that's honestly, that's
I get, that is what we should do.
We should have a dynamic learning rate.
We should not not just have a dynamic
learning rate. We should have dynamic.
All of our hyper parameters be dynamic
and they're all learning in real time and
responding to feedback and optimizing
themselves. This is actually, um,
what's like on the bleeding edge
of machine learning right now.
How do we learn to learn?
So it's kind of like a metal learning.
Three more questions and
then we're out of here.
Is it possible to overshoot the minimum?
Yes.
And so that's why we have a learning
rate so we don't overshoot it. Um,
for larger datasets, yes, we can
absolutely overshoot our minimum.
Our model could just be training
forever and never converge to more.
Are you going to implement
Lstm from scratch? Uh, yeah.
I actually have a video where I do that.
It is a generates Wikipedia articles.
Check that out.
And then one more question.
How large can our dataset
be with this technique?
What if we had billions of data points,
uh,
with this technique? This,
okay, so this technique will
scale this. We'll scale, uh,
and it's a linear,
no pun intended,
relationship to the amount of data
that you have. So the more data,
the longer the training time, but this
will work for larger datasets that, that,
that are linear. So that means that
there's, you know, an x, y value pair,
two values, uh, that you want
to find the optimal form. Okay,
I'll take one more question.
Is the feedback related
to backpropagation? This
is not backpropagation.
So backpropagation is a
form of gradient descent.
This is not backpropagation.
This is gradient descent
for linear aggression.
If we take gradient descent and
apply it to deep neural networks,
that's when it becomes backpropagation.
So grading dissent is
the big is a big boy.
And then backpropagation is
an implementation of grading
the scent where we are
descending or gradient by propagating
an error backwards across all of our
layers. So we go forwards and then we go
backwards. That's it for the questions.
Thanks guys for showing up
and for learning this stuff.
This is the good stuff.
Okay.
It's only going to get better.
It's only going to be a
cooler from here on out. Okay.
So for everything that you learn, moving
on from this is going to be awesome.
So thanks guys for
showing up. Uh, for now,
I've got to go descend my own gradients
in life, so thanks for watching.